all right so welcome to mastering the
middlegame I'm filling in for Ben
Feingold today turns out everybody on
our staff is sick and that includes Ben
so his voice is not in commission today
so I'm gonna be taking over and okay the
little short notice I'm like what should
I do
what who plays really good middle games
and I thought of anatoly karpov so
tonight we're gonna go ahead and have a
look at one of my favorite car pop games
I don't think it's a very famous game
but it's it's very carpeau vien so when
I think of Karpov
I think of Karpov time on off 1983 year
assuming this one it says we can't even
see what your it is so hopefully I know
what I'm talking about because I'm gonna
put it on the bottom and then I'll be so
embarrassed if I'm wrong so we're gonna
go ahead and throw it over to the board
and we'll just get started with this
game right away
okay so Karpov has the white pieces and
the game begins well it's time on of so
they play a time on a Sicilian that
seems appropriate and okay and Karpov
when he plays basically any Sicilian he
always plays the classical variations
very solid goes for a very small plus
and then slowly tries to win in the
middle game so Bishop e2
and he's just gonna Castle kingside play
a move like f4 maybe you play Bishop III
just a very solid chess and already in
this position black plays sort of an
unusual move this move Knight G to e7
more common is Queen to c7 and sort of
the point of this opening for black is
to be very flexible you just start
you're sort of waiting to see how white
chooses to set up so it's a very decent
way to play as black you do a lot of
waiting the night ends up going to f6 so
not like we'll see in the game and then
typically the bishop might go to be four
you get some pressure on e4 and White
has some tactical ways of
his epon that are interesting but not
the focus of tonight's lecture so the
point of this kind of strange move
already nigt e7 is black is going to
trade on d4 and then he's gonna bring
his other knight to c6 he's gonna you
know okay we trade in one of the pieces
and I bring my other night over so
that's fine
Karpov says that's that's fine I just
Castle so he took and okay now we'll
start talking I guess a little bit about
the middle game and I would like to get
the class a little more more involved in
this class so in this position I guess
what would you guys do already I already
put you on the spot the queen is
attacked so you you got to move her
somewhere cuz you might think his move
is a little strange it's a little bit
unusual but it's a very interesting move
and there's probably more than one right
answer so you could say something that's
equally right but if you want to channel
your inner Karpov maybe you can you can
play his mysterious move I guess what's
the most natural move we could start
there you know if you're playing just a
blitz game maybe you got like one second
you make your move what queen d1 yeah I
think this is absolutely the most
natural move so I think this this also
could have been played and okay you just
continue much the same way you know you
just get your stuff out you play a four
very typical and I think here white
probably is a little bit better because
you know well that's how Jeff works no
matter what you're a little bit better
but I think this is very natural you
don't block your bishop in the bishop
will either go to e3 or g5 it's Karpov
so he won't go go that far he'll go to
e3 and what should you know just have a
very decent position here this we can go
a little far there so I think too you
know if you just play some line like
this
you know I think white is a little bit
better but that's probably comfortable
so okay so a very reasonable reply in
the game he chose the unorthodox Queen
to d3 but but wait night before and I'm
not d1 or g3 those you know queen g3 is
like a tactical computer move Queen d2
so very strange just voluntarily
blocking his own bishop
and his idea is to fianchetto the bishop
and get pressure on the King side so
it's a very interesting strategy that he
employs and well it's kind of funny
would uh
what black has chosen to do here well he
traded one of the Knights and then you
know he moves his other night a thousand
times and meanwhile why this castled and
developed so he's perhaps already
thinking you know maybe all getting
attacked going maybe I'll fianchetto my
bishop let's see what happens here okay
so some normal moves so he chose the
bishop all right
alright centralizes his pieces kicks the
night back and now ok he just gets off
this diagonal very sensible know what to
do it so again - he plays just another
slow improving move and so this is the
kind of move that Karpov is really good
at he just decides well at some point I
think black might play a move like d5 so
let me just get my queen off of that
file and it's a nice slow nothing moved
the kind of move that he's really good
at playing and now this move b4 and okay
I think there's several ways that you
could probably handle this position but
again I think I'll I'll throw it over to
this this audience here all right your
Knights attacked so you can take it you
can move your knight back you can move a
knight somewhere else there's what would
you guys do in this this type of
position
there's probably more than one right
answer again
okay so the answer you played just like
Karpov so you're fantastic
yeah night to be won and later you said
you put your night on d2 so that that's
all gonna happen
very good so you took and okay so which
piece should you take with well notice
this guy's pretty good this guy could be
better so I think the the choices he
goes with this night but the night will
still go to d2 later you'll go back and
you were talking before the class to you
like it always retreats so and we does
it it's double X clam and when anybody
else does that it's double question mark
so yeah he's gonna in the future go back
to d2 that's that's how he rolls and in
this position move d5 it's not you again
you might be considering possibly two
things I can play pawn takes d5 I can
play e5 in this position he decides to
first make a little threat a little
threat black black saw it and he pushed
the pond gaining more space like this
this is typical of the kind of attack
that might happen and you might be
wondering well how is this guy gonna be
useful now you just put a pawn in my way
well we'll see we'll see the effect that
that guy might have you might be saying
well this guy he's not the greatest
piece either cuz you know where can he
go
so it might not be all that clear that
what white is accomplishing here but
let's let's have another look okay so
the night is gonna go to f5
very reasonable defending the pond when
you're nice on f5 maybe sometimes I'll
take it
he's done what
okay and we'll see this this possibility
in the future and it would open the
diagonal yeah you're thinking like pond
takes and you can push unleash this guy
okay that's good so you spoiled the
lecture already very good all right
again a simple threat and his opponent
was up for it well this let's pause
again so again I think there's quite a
lot of moves that we might consider so a
lot has changed in this position what do
you guys play here is white wow yeah the
only Ken West Karpov basically the same
person they're so similar and that's
exactly what he played now perhaps it's
tempting to take here this looks
tempting and okay you'll take and I'll
go here and what's what's this all about
looks like things really worked out for
us but I've defended you know this guy
he's adequately defended but okay black
can chomp this guy with the idea of
going here
so if you thought about this line you
may have made a decision okay maybe I
want to go for this maybe I don't
it's it's pretty equal here so you got
opposite colored bishops the black rook
is already very active on the second
rank
okay this bishop might be really good
probably black will double up here maybe
you know this bishop we'll get to some
other very good square and I'll get lots
of pressure here you know I don't know
it's probably balanced maybe he
considered this line and he rejected it
he's like no that's that's two equal and
I think in this position I'm actually
doing quite well I think he was he was
pretty happy with this position he just
said you know I'm not gonna go for that
and game even though I'm Karpov and I
love in games as we'll see you in this
game
this guy he's my worst piece so oh I'll
do my best can west maneuver and I'll
bring my knight to d2
okay g6 extra support for the night 82
heading to g5 excellent how are you
always one step ahead of Karpov you're
too good
you're too good tonight tonight is your
night definitely but okay now this
position we really aren't gonna pause
for a while this is why I'm showing you
the game is this move right here so you
do want to think here at home you might
want to think for a while this is the
position you want to pause and really
take a deep look at because this is this
is why I like this game so much is this
next move right here so I'll give the
audience a little chance here before I
give any hints or anything and then you
know Ken West will spoil it in the next
two seconds and tell us the right move
but until then well we'll take a little
pause g4 would be awful because of d4
okay
g4 yeah that looks annoying because yeah
even if I go here you know you're just
dropping in or something yeah that looks
okay so g4 rolled it out excellent it's
a great start sometimes you got to use
elimination can't watch a lot of movies
you know they're fake you know that
right there acting you've been you've
been deceived this whole time yeah
okay and you're gonna give up this [ __ ]
up and weaken your control over see -
yeah all right this lectures too easy
for this class apparently a lot of avid
Karpov fans so that's exactly what was
played now I think you know a tempting
move is it move like 9f three so I think
that seems like a very supernatural move
and perhaps you saw this and you saw the
move Knight to e3 but if you think a
little bit closer I mean this probably
isn't the best move I could probably
play d4 you know threatening 93
because if here we just have this move
Bishop to d4 okay so let's let's go here
I mean what's the problem well perhaps
I'll throw this move in looks like a
good move to throw in perhaps I'll take
here and however you take back perhaps
I'll take here and I'll crash through on
the light squares okay don't take it
because I'm coming in and now you're
gonna get made it so perhaps you know
you might see a move like Knight f3 and
let's let's suppose that you saw that
this move is impossible it's here
Bishop d4 is very good so you are
sending a mini trap like okay maybe he's
gonna fork me maybe you know he's not
gonna he's gonna think that he has it
and you keep looking and he's like oh
there's a resource here resource here
but it ends up working out very well for
white but perhaps he just didn't like
the move d4 here I mean d4 and my next
move is Knight - III one difference is
now if I just go here I can play h6 and
there's there's no sacrifice or anything
here so if you have to retreat then you
didn't play this you know as brilliantly
as you possibly could've
but in the game we'll go back he took
here on that five and he is gonna
sacrifice the C pawn because after you
take back well how are you gonna defend
your C pond you could bring the Queen
back I suppose but she's doing very well
over here and yes there is this
potential for this Bishop at some point
perhaps I can think of sacrificing upon
so okay he's gonna he's going to attack
cuz here just a column move Knight f3
okay I have my C pawn and now my my
knight is ready to go to g5 but again
what would you guys play here so the
plot is thickening things are really
heating up bishop h3 so you have some
tactical idea what your idea was to go
here
okay you bring your queen in yeah I'm
wondering if I mean I could probably
play here too cuz I have but okay but
yeah I can also just go back yeah it
doesn't work okay it's good we ruled out
giving away our pieces okay but that's
that's a very interesting tactic to
consider something like that you know
might be possible
Bishop anyone okay so you just want to
preserve your bishop I again think I'm
gonna push my my point is if you take
here I'm gonna take it
yeah yeah you know I was gonna take this
take your work
yeah because I think you'd you have to
kind of keep into account what black
wants to do so I'm you know what for
playing d4 and you have some latent
potential here I have some latent
potential here so be sure to d4
excellent yeah by elimination we come to
this move so we keep the bishop on that
diagonal we prevent d5 we gain a tempo
and next move we play Knight g5 so it
does everything alright if I move out of
the way I also notice that this move is
impossible this but uh all right there's
the absolute best move I don't want to
tell you because it is similar to the
game but even a move like rook e1 is is
sufficient so you didn't take that SKUs
even if you see rook b1 you're like okay
it's that's out the h e5 seems like the
most tempting move doesn't it you know 9
g5 it looks as good as it gets
yeah you just push h6 though and if you
have to retreat then this is wrong I
mean perhaps you can think of it
tactical move like e6000 Lee so I really
like you know Bishop takes at five if I
was a great move this 2 is a great move
this again is one of the reasons that I
quite like the way that he plays he
finds all the right accurate moves and
they're usually just slow improving
moves that's what he's he's known for
that's what he did here again so he just
improves the piece yeah Queen h4 you
know the Queen takes up a dark square
you know now right so now sometimes
whenever this happens if I can get on
this diagonal maybe maybe things will be
good for me so now yeah I'm thinking
about going here and here and getting my
knight out of the way and trying this oh
there's he just creeps into the dark
squares okay all right controlling a six
a little more and now how would you guys
continue so I think I just you know
there's probably a couple candidate
moves East sixth night Jay five maybe
something else what would you guys play
in this position
g4 well okay I guess I take it
okay doesn't work
we're not really feeling the temptation
to play g4 like I just don't even
understand what it what this has
accomplished in the position right so
yeah you're opening up your own King
even if this never matters this battery
here I'm not sure how that changed the
position in your your favor opening up
the G file because I don't think you're
gonna get a rook to the G file in time
and I don't think
and so the real theme of this lecture
too is going to be positional pawn
sacrifices maybe I should say that at
the beginning of lecture yeah who's got
the time everybody's sick so we
sacrifice one pond we let you take on
sea to have another he does push it yeah
have another and in the game well let's
roll out there's three ways to capture
let's roll out
the easiest one to refute like g5 on
your queen and threatening me okay
that's the easiest one to refute in the
game he took with a pond though there is
something to be said about sacrificing
the exchange in this position so he
could consider taking with his rook and
after a move like this you gives up the
exchange okay and then you know we take
back so this this is the type of
position that we might be able to
achieve and I can put one of my rooks on
this file you can imagine something like
this let's do all the trading let's go
here so you can imagine something like
this this is the sort of endgame that
you know you might be able to possibly
achieve and I think black does have
quite a lot of drawing chances in this
endgame it's I mean it's got to be a lot
better for white and you don't want to
be slightly worse against Karpov and
endgame but this is a should be taken
into consideration and in a in a serious
way but this is how he decided to take
back
so I've given up two ponds but you'll
also notice in all of the Karpov games
all of his pieces go to good squares no
matter what you know he he always has
his pieces in just the right places and
okay this is no exception so all of his
pieces are quite beautiful black has
some okay pieces a decent rook and these
would be decent pieces if only I could
ever play d4 but he didn't let me do
that now jumps right into the center
just jumps right into the center and
after the Queen moves and so this
happens okay he's got all his pieces and
all these great squares if you got it
look at that cam West yeah he can't take
what this pawn because it's a Gary Maher
mate if that's how you pronounce it how
do you pronounce this mate Gary it on me
did I make it up I don't know yeah it's
like a Pokemon yes it's a Gyarados
checkmate
um you you can't do this with a Magikarp
you just splash around a lot but with a
Gyarados you can actually checkmate the
King in this fashion
I hope you caption that you better
caption what you just said yeah that's
awesome all right
yeah you learned something every day you
learn something every day the Gyarados
checkmate and I do the only reason I
know all the names and all the
checkmates is because I teach like kids
so now I now I already have that joke
ready so so that's good
I learned I learned a lot today that was
good thanks
yeah he just takes and you can't take
back so fantastic we got one of our
ponds back shattering the the black pond
shield okay I would really like to get
your Bishop to move so I can finally
play d4 he says no hey just go back so I
got one pawn back my pieces are still
great your Kings a little more exposed
and now heat car pops it up if I
remember right in some let's see let's
wait from the car pop it up it's coming
it's coming it's coming it's coming just
get ready it's coming
and there's lots of things that I guess
you can do in such a position but he
trades and now he decides okay go ahead
trade Queens that's fine and he's very
happy to go into this slightly better
endgame
so you know it's a very karpova in
victory he's you know he has this
monster attack I'm sacking stuff and let
me be a little bit better in the endgame
so here's where the game really starts
if you're a big Karpov fan oh yes okay
I'm gonna start munching up some of
these guys I'll take this one we'll do a
little bit of trading here you take my
stuff I take some of your stuff and we
get this end game now okay material is
equal but perhaps it'll be a little bit
easier for me to push my pawn perhaps I
can get my rooks to some pretty decent
squares in the night obviously dominates
the bishop so this is the Carpathian
dream this is what you know most people
here tune out well this is where you go
I get started I guess this is this is
where where we want our game to begin so
we'll watch his fantastic technique in
this endgame
all right in comes the rook
we can trade not trade you can trade
with me that's fine all right check darn
now here so if here
well 905 all right good I was able to
solve that I'm the best so okay so you
can't do that just yet and see again
you're not really threatening with that
so we push and okay so again if here now
it's a little bit different now I can
just push and I mean if this happens you
know yeah let me always take this though
okay so this happened and he decides to
stay on this ranks so just preventing f6
for the moment all right and yet so this
is this is exactly what what Karpov
loves you a now here goes my pond and
it's pretty difficult to stop me from
queening here because rookie seven is
gonna run into Knight f5 how do you even
stop me so he goes back he push and
again all I got to do really is bring my
knight into the game
okay and I think there's a lot of ways
you could play you know I could defend
my pond I don't have to push just yet
but he's he's happy just to win a little
bit of material here but my question is
how would you guys take back do they
both win who knows
if you take what the rip tonight doesn't
get back so you actually do win this
though surprised you didn't do it
because it's way more technical and it
seems like you calculate this he did the
other nerve variation because there's no
risk you just drop a piece but uh so
here with best play you should actually
get back it doesn't matter how you start
to get the pawns cuz this night
definitely isn't time to go stop him cuz
he like you know you know I'm coming in
pretty fast I guess and my king is in
the box so I mean I'll be able to get
that guy and under control but it's it's
a lot more technical and probably a
little bit harder so alright I'm happy
I'm up a piece that's that's plenty and
I believe here already black resigned so
you didn't test car pops technique and
peace up if anybody can win a piece up
it's obviously Karpov so it was it was a
very fantastic game so I quite like this
game because it starts with the you know
some aggressive you know we sacrifice
two pawns to bring our pieces to the
absolute greatest squares and instead of
you know some people get so caught up
with yes I'm attacking and you just keep
going and you know you keep sacrificing
stuff and you go a little bit too far we
were talking about going too far when
you when you play buddies just quite
happy like all right I'll just convert
my initiative into a slight plus in the
endgame and he just ground his opponent
down Karpov style so I hope you guys
liked it Ben Feingold we'll be back next
week so we look forward to a lot more of
him and until then we'll see you guys
next week
you